hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from round seven
of the tata steel chess tournament 2021
uh in a game between pentala hari
krishna and
alireza firuja ah hare krishna so far
without a loss he has one win against
niels from round four uh whereas alireza
lost his first round game to magnus
carlsen if you remember that crazy game
we've uh
we've shown immediately after it
finished uh but alireza also has
three wins so alireza is uh trying to
catch up
to the leaders of the tournament uh so
like i said it's a pretty pretty wild
game uh let's see what happens
uh so hari krishna with the white pieces
opens with
d4 uh we have d d five but there is a c4
and now a c6 going for the slav defense
and
hari krishna exchanges once we have
captures captures and now
bishop to f4 uh we have knight to c6
valereza and
now e3 closing up this uh structure here
now that the dark square bishop has been
developed and here the the top move
in the database is knight to f6 but
alireza decides to mix it up with bishop
to f5
and here we have bishop to b5 and
already as of move six we have a
completely new game
uh some someone asked in the comments on
the previous video what does it mean a
completely new game i i often
mention this like every 100 videos or so
uh so there are these uh storages of uh
of chess games called the databases and
then we can check
all the all the games for for moves so
whenever i
analyze uh for uh for example this game
i
check if any of the moves uh were played
who played and why they were played uh
how many times
a certain move has been played and then
i know uh whenever we reach a certain
position that has never been reached
before
i personally consider that to be very
interesting and
a lot of you said that you also consider
this to be interesting that we know that
we are now covering new grounds
so that's why what i mean when i say we
have a completely new
new game uh just putting that out there
so bishop to b5 never played before a
completely new move
uh and already as of move six so here
alireza just continues developing with
e6 he also closes up this structure and
now
knight to c3 uh we have knight to e7
could be very useful in the future you
can go knight g6 attack the bishop maybe
go h5 h4
and so on so here rook to c1 and we have
a6 now asking do you want to trade or
i'm just going to push back your bishop
so bishop back to e2
and now f6 alireza doesn't mind
weakening
the e6 pawn a little bit because he he
wants to start pushing here
so here g4 uh hari krishna beats him to
it
attacks the bishop bishop to g6 and now
knight to f3
so you've also made some room under on
g3 for bishop if needed
with bishop to f7 now adding additional
support to the e6 pawn and preparing to
to push those king side pawns uh bishop
back to g3
and now alareza goes for h5 so he wants
to open up the h file for his rook
hari krishna doesn't allow it he pushes
g5 and now
knight the g6 and already here we have a
very interesting moment in the game
uh where it's uh like we said it was a
new new uh
position already as the move six so this
is a very very uncovered uncovered
ground
uh and here you should play h4 just uh
support that pawn on g5
prevent black from playing h4 and your
position is good but here hare krishna
captured on f6
and this is where his troubles begin
because now
of course uh he was hoping for g
captures on f6 and then he's going to
play h4
and everything is perfectly fine however
uh he missed
one uh one tuition two that alireza had
in mind so after g
captures on f6 alireza says uh nope not
gonna capture that i'm just gonna push
h4 and now you you're kind of in a
a bit of a a bit of a bit of trouble uh
because the bishop
has to go somewhere and wherever you
play the bishop the knight will capture
it and
with the game being uh very very open uh
you kind of
do want the advantage of the bishop
player so here uh f captures on g7 first
bishop captures and now
bishop to e5 you have to give it up but
black will also
recapture his lost pawn so we have
knight g captures on e5
d captures and here alireza just grabs
it knight captures on e5
and now knights to d4 avoiding the trade
and also
hoping to put some pressure on that weak
e6 pawn
so rook to c8 alireza brings the rook
into the game and here
white castles and it's very interesting
that white castles here the whole
position is very interesting
uh like where is white castling where is
black castling
uh white doesn't have a g pawn uh the
entire king side is
shattered black has no pawns on the king
side
it's uh not a position you see every day
but here for example if rook to g1
uh you might think why should i castle i
might use the g file for my rook but
then let's say bishop f6
and you can see that all of these
squares are covered by the bishops this
is covered by the knight discovered by
the pawn
so the the rook will not have all that
much to do here on the g
file so instead of uh bringing the rook
to g1
uh uh hari krishna just castled
uh and now alireza plays knight to c6
now he's uh putting some pressure on the
knight here
uh he has some ideas of of pushing the
pawns in the center
and also if something like rook to g8
you don't have to worry the king will be
safe on h1
it's not um the position is very
unlikely to open up that
the the white king will be in danger so
here bishop the g4
again just putting pressure on that e6
pawn so alireza eliminates one of the
attackers knight captures e
captures and now rook to c6 just a nice
rook lift to add more defense to the to
the pawn here
in the future you might have some ideas
of shifting the rook over to the king
side
for attacking purposes so knight to e2
uh adding a a defender to this d4 pawn
because
black always has this option of adding
more uh more pressure to the pawn so
this defends it and also it offers a
trade-off of rooks so here
alireza says uh let's play h3 and
h3 is a very nice idea because it uh
prevents white from playing h3
and it's such a such a you know it's
always
ugly when you have to play uh and your
opponent has his pawn all the way to
your king you constantly have to
calculate everything
like if the bishop moves maybe like
ideas like queen g5 checking h1 queen to
g2 checkmate to become possible all of a
sudden
so uh here rook to c3 saying that okay
you will either capture here and then
i'm going to recapture with my pawn and
have a very strong center
or i'm just going to capture this pawn
on h3 which is now obviously a weakness
but alireza says
obviously not and plays rook to h4
now saying that if you go after the pawn
the problem is after for example bishop
captures
rook captures on c3 you eliminate one of
the defenders and then you just pick up
the
the bishop or of course if you if you
capture with the rook then you lose the
bishop
so here hare krishna plays rook to g3
and now queen to c7 just putting putting
more pressure to that king side
and here while you can capture on h3
there's
no point in doing it right away for
example captures a bishop h5 now it's
very annoying
so it doesn't seem like there's uh ever
a good time to capture this pawn for now
so here rook the e1 first and now king
to f8 getting the king to safety away
from the e file
uh we have queen to d3 and now comes
e5 so now the the queen is uh has left
the d1 square
now maybe now you will be able to
capture an h3
but already starts pushing in the center
e5 and the e5 is a very sneaky move
uh you're threatening a lot of stuff
here
for example capturing the d4 pawn you
might have ideas of pushing the pawn to
e4
and white needs to take all of this uh
into account so here
you might consider moving the queen you
might consider bishop captures an h3 you
might consider king h1 a lot of
a lot of moves are possible here before
doing any of that
uh hari krishna decided to deliver this
queen to a3 check
just checking to see if the king will
move uh to the g
file in line of the rook or will maybe
already a block with the queen
so as black is the one who's attacking
here uh pantala
uh really wants to get the queens off
the board and alareza says nope not a
problem
uh goes queen to d6 and we have a queen
trait captures captures and now finally
bishop captures an h3
saying that okay you're either going to
advance the pawn and then i'm going to
be up a pawn or you capture on d4 and
then your
pawn structure in the center is all
messed up uh but
alireza says that's that's not a problem
just captures on the e4
this pawn is very well protected and now
because you capture the h3 pawn you're
gonna have some problems here along the
h file when i double up my rooks here
so knight the c1 uh and now rook
d h6 going after that bishop and the
pawn so you have to move the bishop
bishop
to g2 and then now comes rook captures
on h2
we have knight to d3 and now a rook back
to h5
just taking away that e5 square from
from the white knight
so f4 here with options of
maybe getting the knights the e5 and
maybe you want to
start pushing that pawn if the
opportunity will arrive
but here alireza just goes rook to c6 he
says i want to get my rook all the way
to the second rank
and then my position will be just
unstoppable
uh so here uh bishop to f3 going after
the rook we could
we could play 95 but it doesn't seem to
be sufficient for example captures
captures
and now blocks with bishop to e6 and
black's black's position will always be
better here for example if rook d1 going
after the pawn
rook the c2 so you can take one of the
doubled pawns it's not really a problem
but
black will be very happy with his
activity along the second rank so here
after rook to c6 we have bishop to f3
first
challenging the rook here and now rook h
to h6
we have rooked back to g2 uh not
allowing rook to c2
this rook lift and now rook h to g6 here
alireza
offers a trade of one of the rooks and
hare krishna says all right but
we trade uh on g2 and here uh if you
capture on g2 for example captures
captures in rook c2 yes you've
you got your rook to the second rank but
after king to g3
now there's no no good way uh to take
advantage of this the knight is still on
d3 guarding the pawn here
so it's not really that big of a deal uh
so and if you go for example rook to
rook to d2 you attack the knight then
for example knight c5 and now
finally if you capture it then you have
this knight to e6 check and it's a
very very uh tricky position rook
captures
uh now this can be captured this is this
is going to be pushed and uh
it's uh it's an equal-ish position
so instead after f5 alireza doesn't like
that he goes back rook to h6
and now we have knight to f4 so knight
to f4
is looking uh looks very scary but it is
in fact the mood that
allows aloe reza a winning advantage but
for
alerisa to win this you have to pause
the video and try to find the winning
idea for him
while i give you a couple of seconds
so you know do your thing
so uh uh for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on spotting the
unspottable move
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show uh it's
nothing to do with rook but it's d3 so
congratulations to everyone who found it
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show the reason why d3 is so
strong
is because it can be captured and it's
hard to find
the reasoning behind this move but when
you see it then you of course
believe it so here not capturing the
pawn
doesn't really make sense it's too
strong upon to be just left there
and now rook to c2 is again an option
because the pawn is just
uh will be defending that so you have to
eliminate
this pawn so this is what hare krishna
did but now comes
bishop to d for check and that was the
point of the pawn push you have to free
up the d4 square for the bishop
and now the problem is if you for
example go king f1
then rook to h3 and now the knight on d3
is terrible
and there's no good way to deal with
this you have to give up material
because if you try to hold on to
everything
let's say you defend the knight just
rook h1 check rook g1
rogue g1 checkmate so great stuff there
so after bishop to d
for check we have knight to f2 by hari
krishna
and now rook to c2 finally alireza
brings his rook to the second rank
and not going for the for the greedy
bishop characters here activity
is always above all so here king f1
white unpins here and now rook captures
on b2 now he will gobble up those pawns
we have rook to e2
uh offering a rook trade now rook b1
check rook to e1
and now rook h back to b6 now saying
okay you can trade here but then my
other rook comes
uh to the to the b1 square with check
and now if you go up the board then i
can always check you pick up the pawn
or if you play something like this then
it's just a very very passive position
for white
not uh not not fun to play so uh after
this rook h to b6 we have knight to d3
and now bishop to c3 attacking the rook
here we have rook captures on b1
forcing the trade rook captures and king
f2 and now
alareza starts bringing the king into
the game king e7
we have rook to h2 now with ideas of
shifting the rook over to the seventh
rank
king f6 and now king to e3 and here
king to g5 vial it is and king to g5 is
very very interesting because it kind of
invites rook to h7
uh and there doesn't seem to be a uh
an idea behind it what all it is had in
mind i have no idea probably to go back
with the king if
if he goes for this uh but if you're
wondering why not just capture the pawn
this is not a free pawn if you capture
it then there's bishop captures on d5
uh bishop captures now rook h5 check
with the idea of capturing the bishop
and if the king defends
knight f4 uh checks and picks up the
bishop here
and uh white will white will be very
happy with this position as
it's the best one he can get from from
there
so instead king to g5 not capturing this
pawn and now
here hare krishna did not even test what
happens after
rook to h7 he decided to go for knight
the c5
instead puts put some pressure on the b7
pawn now
his idea is rook to h7 might come on the
next move
uh and here rook to b5 trying to kick
away the knight
but now rook to h7 trying to trade
knight for bishop here
but just bishop the g8 of course you do
not have this check the bishop covers
that square
so rook to c7 and now finally king
captures on f5 now it's
it's all right to capture it and here
white is up
black is up two pawns and white really
needs to
do something about that the two being
two ones down is uh
not great uh but it's hard to hard to
find a move for white
there's there doesn't seem to be an
active idea uh so
white uh went with the with the idea
that let's just grab a pawn and if we
survive then we survive
so here hare krishna played knight
captures on b7
but now again alireza just goes in for
the kill and plays
d4 with check and now how do you survive
this
your options are very limited you could
go king d3
for example king f2 let's see what
happens if king to d3 if king d3
then king f4 attacks the bishop you move
the bishop
and then comes rook to b2 with the idea
of this
check so you have to prevent that bishop
the c2 but now
bishop to e6 with the idea of bishop f5
check and then you win the game
so knight to d6 blocking this and now
just bishop to b4
they are preparing to eliminate the
defender of the f5 square and that's it
there's no defending
there's no defending this try something
like rook to a7
it doesn't help because the bishop just
moves and now the knight is under attack
you have to defend it and here you just
capture captures captures and king e5
and that's it now you have to give up
the rook for the bishop or you move the
rook and then again this check comes and
then you pick up the piece
and so on so it's a very very uh
it's an impossible position to play for
white so king to d3 out of the question
king to f2 is what was played in the
game
uh and here alireza goes uh rook to b2
with check
bishop to e2 and now king f4 just uh
limiting the options of of this white
king uh
this is for the moment not the greatest
of moves because the bishop will fall so
uh
all there is i will simply prepare that
knight to d6
and now bishop to d2 now d3 becomes a a
real threat so here king to f1 getting
the king away from
uh the second rank that the rook
occupies and now
rook to b1 with check and now the
problem is if you go something like king
f2 then bishop to e2
uh sorry bishop to e3 with check is just
deadly king g2
and you're getting checkmated bishop
here delivers check king
goes here and now rook to h1 will be
checkmate so instead after rook the b1
check uh here bishop to d1 was played
kinda
kinda getting into maybe if rook
captures just king here
and then we you know pick up the pick up
the bishop or the rook
the problem is bishop a5 again attacks
white's rook so that this
is uh not possible but alireza did not
uh
go for the um for the immediate grab
alireza just played the d3
and it was in this position on mu 56
that pentala hari krishna resigned the
game
uh as there is nothing more to be done
here uh
like th there is nothing real captures
on d1 is coming and
that's just it you're getting checkmated
whatever you play uh
especially like if you go after the
bishop is just an immediate checkmate
rook captures with uh
check king f2 bishop to e3 check king to
g2 now bishop d5 check you have to go up
the board and then just
rook to h1 will be checkmate so
incredible
win by alireza with the black pieces
and this means uh a lot for the current
standings as
after seven rounds of the tata steel uh
masters uh
these are the standings so let's check
it out uh alireza
is on top with five and a half points
out of eight having an incredible
uh tournament with uh with a rating
performance of 28.62 so that's just
incredible
uh alone with five and a half points
then four people with five points
uh anishigiri andreas penco jordan van
forest and fabiano corona
with four and a half nils grandelius uh
pentala and magnus are on four out of
eight
with three and a half radius lavoiters
with three we have maximum vaseline
and david anton guiharro and uh in last
place
alexander donchenko which two and a half
out of out of eight
so imagine if alireza didn't lose uh to
magnus in
in the first round uh he would be he
would be up a full point ahead of ahead
of everyone
and also something i wanted to show you
uh if you guys are interested let me
just load that
load that up uh just give me a second
uh alireza's rating is currently
uh very very impressive uh
oh come on me and my
file namings uh oh it's oh it's a all
right yes esh
why don't i see it all right yeah i
think it's this one
no it's not oh come on
oh there we go all right nice all right
so these
uh are the alive ratings and as you can
see
ferruja is up by 11 points so that's
super super impressive and he's now
currently number 14
in the world and he's very very close he
needs
uh how many points to get in the top 10
he needs
less than five points so he needs less
than five rating points
to take over everyone richard rapport
van gaal rajabov and maxine vashilagrav
and then go into the world top ten and
as you can see magnus is
down by 17.7 points but
that's the uh the the downside of being
uh so much higher rated than
everyone else if you lose a game uh it's
gonna really really hurt uh
your rating as as you can see here so if
magnus loses one more game he might even
go below below fabi okay not one but
it's uh it does hurt when uh
he loses to for example uh esipenko like
he did there as icypenko was over 200
rating points lower rated than magnus
but yeah really incredible stuff and
yeah we'll see what happens can ali
can firuja continue this onslaught he
already faced magnus in round one so
uh we will we'll see if anyone else can
can challenge him
so that's uh the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank
eric hinterbilla uh mike marshall ian
tomaca
ramdan smith macleod and jared langdon
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the tata steel
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chest world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day